Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two lifelong
friends talk about life
for a long time.
Well, I mean, not that long.
You know, about an hour.
Just long enough.
That's a long time for an ant.
Who are you?
I'm Rhett.
There you go, so you forgot that part,
you did screw it up.
No, you interrupted me.
I didn't.
You said...
I could tell in your eyes you
weren't gonna say your name.
You said not that long of a time.
What's your name?
I interjected.
What if it was a custom,
like a cultural custom
in America that you
could only say your name
when asked?
Like a vampire can only
enter when invited?
Yes, I feel like that would
be a good societal rule,
because instead of people
coming in with like,
I'm Rhett, it's be like, I
only wanna know your name
if I ask it.
What's your name?
And I'm Link.
This week at the round table
at not as dim of lighting
because we're still in the
alternative creative house
location.
Maybe permanently, I don't know.
We are discussing, we're
bathing in the aftermath
of our separate, but equal vacations.
Separate but equal vacations.
Potentially identical vacations.
I know we both went to
beaches, we both endeavored
to surf.
Uh-huh, we both took our families.
We both took our families,
we both came back with
one less family member.
Oh, that's a tease.
No, I took a head count before
and I took a head count...
What if that was the case?
I always take a head count.
Oh crap, you're right.
I left Shepard.
I'm like a chaperone,
count heads on the plane.
Well I have an extra
family member right now,
'cause we have Locke, as friend
who's been living with us,
I don't even know how long it's been now.
So I know what it's
like to have three kids.
I've had three kids for two months.
Is he pulling his weight?
He does more than both
of my children combined.
Great.
He's very helpful.
Like what, like chores?
I'm thinking about hiring him.
So he does chores?
He just is a more conscientious person
than my kids, and maybe
it might be because...
You're trying him out for a trade.
When you're... yeah, can you do that?
Sure.
When you are at, now this
is what I've been told,
because I, a lot of times,
I have parents who...
I have parents too.
Who come to me and they're like,
you know, Locke is so conscientious,
or he's really helpful,
and he's so polite,
and he's a great conversationalist,
and he offered to help with this,
and he said thank you.
And I'm like, well, he
didn't do that at home?
He's a jerk at home.
I talked to, I'm not
gonna mention any names,
but I talked to one of my children,
who happens to be one of the oldest one.
Who happens to be one of the
oldest, or the oldest one.
I kinda feel like maybe I
didn't center this shot.
Is there more of me in it?
I feel like there's more of,
I'm closer to the center.
And I didn't do that on purpose.
That's not good.
I mean, 'cause I feel like...
It's fine.
You know what?
Just go with it.
You've got a little bit of,
I've got like a full six
inches off my shoulder.
I'm gonna do a little
adjustment, just keep going.
No, I can do it.
Oh yeah, you're closer, see.
Wrong way.
How's this?
Too much, that's too much of you.
I think this is pretty good.
That's way too much of you.
I think that's it, I
think that's centered.
Yeah, spoken like a semi narcissist.
Okay, stop.
How is that?
Oh, that's nice, oh, see it
gets a bit of the skin wall
in there.
That's the ticket.
Oh, a little peek at the skin wall.
You get a peek of the skin wall,
that's how you know you're centered.
We have the discussions,
I want you to treat me like
you would treat your friends
like at least at that level.
I'm not asking for the respect
of a parent all the time,
I'm just asking for the
respect you would give
any other human being.
Wow, just a minimum.
Yeah.
Of respect.
Yeah, it's like,
what I say is, I hope you don't
treat your friends this way.
Oh, I get that.
I don't want to talk about this anymore,
because I'll get in trouble,
I'll get more of it.
Yeah, so we had our vacations,
we came back with more tan.
Yeah, yeah, we did.
I mean, you're talking
about the skin walls,
I mean I'm looking at my skin wall.
People have been noticing
that you have been getting
closer to matching my skin wall,
which incidentally, we didn't plan this,
because we didn't know
we were gonna record
Ear Biscuits in here,
but we should've done
the skin walls on opposite sides.
Because now you sit in
front of my skin wall,
which is, you know, to the naked eye,
it's the same as your skin wall.
If you're just in here
looking at em side by side,
you'll be like, well
that's the same color.
One is Lakehouse, and
one is, what's yours?
It's a guy's name.
Chadwick Brown.
I don't know why I remember that.
It just came back to you?
It came to me, man.
That's Chadwick Brown, that's Lakehouse,
but you're looking pretty Lakehouse,
I'm looking pretty Chadwick Brown.
And I, you know what, I'm
rejuvenated and baked.
Yeah.
Well, I mean, I'm sun baked.
Well, interestingly,
so we usually go on
vacations at the same time,
because, you know, our lives
are in sync in a lot of ways,
and if you go on vacation
at a different time
when I go on vacation,
and then that means well
now I gotta go on vacation
when you're not on vacation,
and that's two weeks of
us not being together.
Who knows what could
happen in those two weeks?
One might think that we
should stagger our vacations
in order to like, 'cause there's a whole,
other stuff that we give input on,
it's not just being on camera together
to like run a company.
Correct.
But we just do that remotely.
And we have very trusted
people who can handle it
for a week.
Yeah.
Which is great.
Maybe they can handle it for more.
Maybe we just, what if
the default is vacation?
I like where this is going.
I mean, let's face it,
what we're doing right now
is still another form of vacation.
It is.
We're just, you know, we're in a house.
No, this is work, man.
Look.
We're working so hard, you've
got your Admiral hat on.
I got a new hat, that's one
of the things I brought back,
I didn't bring back another
child, I already had one,
but I did bring back a captain's,
you call it Admiral's hat?
I like that.
On a scale of one to 10,
just to get into this,
how would you rate your
vacation and then dive in, man?
I got a lot I need to report on.
I got a story.
Oh, I got stories.
I got angry.
Oh.
To me, I'll let you rate first,
but when I rate my vacation,
there's a corollary to
how many times I got angry,
either at other people or myself,
or just kinda lost my cool, or my peace.
Oh man.
That happened once, so I
had a pretty good vacation,
if I can only say that happened once.
Well, okay, so on a scale of one to 10...
I'll tell you about it.
And I'm gonna say that
an eight is like what
you bring in, like the
expectations that you bring in
to a vacation.
Yeah, you don't expect a perfect...
You know some things are gonna go wrong,
but you're kinda hoping,
you're usually hoping for about an eight,
like this is gonna be
better than my normal life,
right?
'Cause it's a vacation.
And then in like nine and
10, that would be like,
I don't know if that's
ever happened, right?
Four.
Oh gosh.
I mean, you had a brightness in your eyes,
I wouldn't have asked the question.
I mean I thought I was
lobbying you something
to knock outta the park, man.
No, man.
You freaking had a four?
I had a four.
That's not, I mean it could've been,
I had a seven.
Oh, well look, it's not a competition.
I'm sorry.
I mean we should talk
about the COVID of it all
before we get into vacation too much,
'cause it's...
That could've attributed to it.
We had planned vacations.
I mean, I was going to
freaking Disney World
with my extended family,
and the first few weeks of quarantine,
of course that got obliterated.
And then I was gonna
go home for July fourth
and see the rest of my
family, that got obliterated,
I was gonna go up to Santa Cruz,
I had booked a place up there,
that was earlier on in quarantine,
that got obliterated,
and then it got to a
point where it's like,
I'm just not, we're at home,
we're gonna be at home,
I'm gonna go into the office
the minimum amount of time
with the minimum amount of people
and be absolutely as safe as possible.
We don't go out and do anything,
and when we do, we're
doing the mask thing,
I mean all of that is
still in full effect.
Yeah, you're basically
just staying at home,
but just a different home.
So yeah, we did like
an AirBnB at the beach,
with like their cleaning certification,
and then we just hunkered down there.
And we went South, and I
mean LA, at least right now,
it's one of the hotspots,
so technically, technically, leaving LA
and hunkering down somewhere else,
I mean, you're a little bit lower risk,
this is a hotspot, man.
But we are high risk
going into that place,
so for the sake of
everybody else, I'd still.
But we're not, because
we've been isolated here.
Now, okay.
So it's like just being
at home, at the house
that we rented, wearing a mask
all the way to the beach,
to where we set up a spot
that is then well
distanced beyond six feet
from everybody else.
And then getting in the
water just with my family.
That was the game plan,
that's what happened.
A lot of my experience the entire time
was man, this would be really awesome
if we weren't in a global pandemic.
Like that's kinda like,
oh, that restaurant
would be cool to go into.
That store would be cool to go into.
This would be an awesome place to be,
but there's this, you feel,
you're conscious of the
fact that there's a pandemic
going on, and so you never
are super relaxed until
you're like seated on the beach.
Right.
The process of getting to the beach,
you're just kind of thinking about things
that you typically don't think about,
and so, that contributed to it,
not being as good of a vacation
as vacations used to be before COVID,
but the main thing that happened to me...
Yeah, that can bring you to a four,
because just being,
I mean, we're blessed to be
able to go on a vacation.
Yeah, yeah.
And we know that.
But the thing is is that I have a problem,
I've talked about it before,
and I think this is pretty common.
People you tie expectations to things,
whether it's a vacation,
a project, whatever,
but vacations are the
things that most people tie
a certain level of expectation to,
and you think about it
and you fool yourself
into thinking that like,
oh, but when I go on vacation,
that's gonna be a great week.
Like, oh, that vacation week at the beach,
man, that's gonna be good.
'Cause that's the point of it.
And then I started thinking things like
well, what am I gonna do on the vacation,
'cause I wanna make sure
that I'm doing the vacation well, right?
And so then my sort of expectation was,
and first of all, I'm a lot
more aware of this than I was,
say 10, 20 years ago,
where I unconsciously went into situations
with all these expectations
and then I was disappointed.
At least I had gotten to a point
where I know the way my mind works is
you have these expectations,
you need to set low expectations,
you need to go with the flow,
but I just find myself
getting to the place
where I've still got the expectations,
and the expectations of this vacation were
I want to actually get a
lot of surf time in, right?
I wanna surf, but I also
wanna get my kids surfing,
pretty much for the first time,
locking down a little bit
earlier in the summer.
And, me and you stand
up paddleboard, surf,
and I've had this secret
hope to be able to...
You don't believe that counts.
To regular... well, the thing is is that
there's lots of places in
the world that if you go
and you didn't bring your
big ass paddleboard with you,
you don't have an option to surf,
and then there's also a
lot of really cool breaks
where you're not really supposed to be,
you're not even allowed to
be on a stand-up paddleboard
in some places.
So I was just like, I would
just like to have that in
my arsenal of abilities,
the ability to like surf,
and I'm not talking about like hang ten,
or catch big, I'm talking
like old man on a long board,
like just the bare
minimum, catching the wave.
I get that, you want the versatility.
So I was like, okay, San Diego,
it's an easier surf town,
we were on various beaches
between LA and San Diego,
but we were closer to San Diego,
and it's just easier to surf down there,
it's less territorial,
there's more places to surf,
there's less people, whatever.
So I was super excited about that,
and we were like walking
distance from a place that
was like a good place to learn.
And I took my long board
that I bought this year
down there.
And day one, I go out,
and it's frustrating,
it's frustrating when you
know that you could be
already standing up on a
paddleboard and surfing.
Yep.
But you're sitting there,
trying to stand up,
and like not balancing,
falling off the board.
Yeah, it kinda reminds me
when we decided to start
snow skiing even though we
were both pretty decent at
snowboarding.
Exactly, like I know how to do this.
You have to invest like a whole ski trip
just to learn how to do something
when you could be enjoying
it doing the thing
you already know how to do.
Right.
So, day one was pretty frustrating.
There were a couple of moments of hope.
And the reason you ski is 'cause
as you get older, it's
like it's better on your...
Well, it's harder on your
knees, easier on your back,
for me.
That's why I transitioned to skiing.
It's not good on the pelvis.
And that's why I transitioned
to stand up paddle boarding
'cause it's easier on the back for me.
Case in point, day two, I go out,
and I don't know exactly what is going on,
but one of the things that
has always happened to me,
it used to happen before
I would go on a vacation,
or before there was a
significant transition,
or in the midst of a transition.
I would have my lower back act up
and basically...
Your back would go out.
Go back to what I call
my ground zero injury,
which is related to my herniated disc,
it's in a very specific spot
in the left side of my spine
and then, you know, 10 years
ago, when this would happen,
even five years ago,
when this would happen,
I would be out, I would
be in pain for months
when this happened.
Now I've gotten to a place
where I can experience
that injury
and then a few days later I'm
pretty functional or whatever
and now, a week later,
as I'm about to tell you,
I did hurt my back.
But, the second day, I
wake up, and first of all,
the X factor of any
vacation is the bed, right?
What is this bed gonna
be like in this AirBnB?
When you got a bad back,
you're very sensitive
to beds in general
and the softer the bed, the
worse it is on your back.
That's the case for a lot of
people with back problems.
I was like, man, this bed
is unnecessarily soft.
I love a soft bed, my bed was too hard.
We should've swapped.
I almost slept on the floor
for most of the time, but I didn't,
there was a mattress
topper, I took that off
after the second night,
but got up that second day
and was like, man, my back is tight,
but I did all my stuff
that I do to loosen up.
Locke and I go down to
the beach and second wave
standing up, and I feel
like oh, there it is,
oh no, oh no, oh no, and
it's like a sharp pain,
but then I'm like, okay,
but no, I'm in better shape,
let me just go in, I'm gonna
do some stretches on the beach,
like an old man.
So you rode two waves, and the second one.
Well, I didn't ride the
wave, I was in the process
of standing up when it went out on me.
And then you fell over.
And then I swim in to the
beach, I get on the beach,
I do my stuff,
and then it hits me very,
very squarely and clearly,
you're not going back out today.
And so, I like wave at Locke
and I'm like I gotta go in.
He was like, okay, and he
stays out there by himself.
I walk back to the
house, carrying my board,
which is not feeling great,
because I gotta walk
like a quarter mile or so
with this board, my back is hurting.
'Cause standing up on a...
it's an explosive act.
Yeah.
To go from paddling on your
chest to like standing up
on a board.
I was trying to show
Lincoln how to do that
'cause there were foam
boards that happened to be
at the place we stayed,
'cause I don't own any of those,
'cause, I didn't wanna
make that transition,
but I'm like, hey, it's here,
and I'm showing him on the beach
how to stand up, and it's explosive,
and there's twisting involved too.
You're supposed to be turning your hips.
I don't know, I can imagine
that it can really...
Well, but here's the thing...
Wring your back.
And you know, I was talking
about this in therapy
because...
Physical therapy?
I do,
I don't wanna get into too much woo,
and I don't know exactly
what I think about this,
but I do know that there's a connection
to emotional sort of pain and stress
that manifests itself physically
in ways that we don't quite understand.
Okay.
This has just been
proven many, many times.
Like, I told you, every
time I get ready to
go on vacation or I'm in
the midst of a vacation,
there are many years where my back would,
I could just feel it tensing up, right?
'Cause it's like the act of relaxing,
and it's very difficult for me to relax
on vacation.
I'll talk about a little
bit more lately, later.
And so I think the act of
trying to relax a little bit,
plus the bed, plus the
act of doing something,
I don't know exactly what
the pie chart is that
contributed to it, but
it was the perfect storm.
But all that to say I was
immediately deflated, right?
And it felt like, 'cause I was like...
Can't surf the rest of the week.
I was like am I gonna be able
to surf paddle board at all?
I'm not gonna be able to surf at all
for the rest of the week, and this is,
a very privileged problem,
but also I was upset because the AirBnB,
which came with a hot tub,
the hot tub wasn't working
and they were like,
we can't fix it while you're there.
Because the manufacturer said it's broken,
it has to be replaced or something.
So I was like, oh, I hurt my back
and I also can't get into
the hot tub to make myself
feel better.
Wah, wah!
So that's a four, you plummeted.
Yeah, and I was like...
Or is that lower than a four?
No, well, okay, so when it happened to me,
as I was walking back to the house
thinking about the fact
that my expectations
had been thwarted, I was like,
of course this is what
has happened, right?
Because.
What do you mean?
'Cause you think you deserve it?
You deserve to be punished?
No, no, it's not about being deserving,
it's just like this is the
perfect gift from the universe
for someone who is bringing
this level of expectations.
If what you really want to learn how to do
is to accept things, to go with the flow,
to not have all of these
expectations tied up
in your experiences,
but to let things happen to you,
to let things come to you,
'cause even when I'm out there surfing,
it's very difficult for me to have fun,
because I'm focused on doing it well,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm like, you gotta get up
and you gotta catch this wave,
it's like I approach it
like an athletic event
versus like an enjoyable thing
'cause there's this part
of me that's just like,
you gotta get good enough at this
before you can enjoy it.
If you get good enough at it,
then you can actually sit
back and reap the benefits
of the joy that comes from it.
So long story short is
my back got better enough
to stand up paddle
board, the very last day,
I had a really good surfing day,
caught a bunch of waves,
it kinda redeemed the experience,
but the fact that my expectations
were kinda ripped apart,
I didn't learn how to do regular surfing,
I wasn't able to surf,
even on a paddle board
for two days after I hurt my back.
It was almost like the
vacation was a lesson.
And lessons aren't fun,
so it wasn't like, oh, I'm
having an incredible time
doing the thing that I
thought I was gonna do,
I'm really just kinda sitting here wishing
that I was doing the thing
that I thought I was gonna do.
It's interesting you
say lessons aren't fun,
but do you think that you would
have enjoyed your vacation
more if you didn't see it as a lesson,
that you just said, oh, I have an injury,
now I gotta pivot to just
watching Netflix the whole time
I'm here?
Well, I'll talk about that later.
'Cause that is what I did, and
that created another sort of
weird emotional experience to it.
Okay, dang, man.
I'm very in touch with myself.
But seeing it as a lesson,
you said lessons aren't fun,
but I actually think that this mindset
of accepting what happened to you
as something to learn from,
didn't that help redeem it a little bit?
Yeah, yeah, it did, but it wasn't...
It wasn't fun in a recreational sense,
but it was valuable.
It's like the process,
I was reading this book where the woman
was talking about the process
of sort of transformation
that takes place in people
who are trying to change
and the process of change,
she uses the analogy of like leather,
you know?
Tanning a hide.
Okay.
And like, you know, at
first it's just really hard,
it's not pliable at all,
it's like a big potato chip.
It's like raw hide, like
what you would give your dog
to eat.
But the process of tanning and stretching
and hanging it up, I don't
know what happens to leather,
but eventually it becomes nice and supple
but if you imagine yourself as this hide,
going through that process,
you're being stretched
and you're in the sun,
it's not fun, but you're
becoming what you're supposed
to be becoming, and I
know that's not what they,
again, that's not what they...
A seat for a cowboy's crotch.
That's not what vacation is,
vacation is traditionally
like a break from the norm,
it's a time to relax, it's a time to,
when you live, yeah, we
have an incredible job,
we're living the dream,
but it's very busy and
there's constantly things
we have to engage with.
Trying to disengage,
which is difficult for me,
for me it was just that
lesson of not getting
what you thought you wanted
but getting what you actually needed.
I'm just saying, when
you asked that question,
on a scale of one to 10, I'm
thinking the enjoyment factor,
maybe the long term
value of it, it's a 10,
versus if I had gone down
there and learned how to surf
and it was awesome it would've
been a one in the long term
value.
But once the injury happened,
seeing it through the lens
of how can I grow here,
it helps.
Redeemed it.
I mean...
It redeemed it, but the
lesson wasn't enjoyable.
Okay.
'Cause everyday I was like,
man, I wish I was surfing right now
and thinking that oh, even when I do surf,
I'm gonna have to be on
the stand up paddle board,
I already know how to do that,
that's no fun,
you know what I'm saying?
That's how I was thinking about it.
Ironically that's when it should be fun,
'cause that's what you said earlier.
Right.
That when you know how to...
Well if it makes you feel any better,
I also suffered an injury.
Oh, good.
Yeah, I really did.
You know, I tried to psych myself up
to low expectations,
I was like...
Psych yourself up for low expectations.
Yeah, for the same reason,
because I always have an
idea of what the perfect
anything is, and so there's this standard
that I'm constantly trying to meet,
and bring my family along
to meet that same standard,
so I was just telling myself...
Which severely complicates it,
when other people, you're
expecting other people,
it's even worse.
You know what? This is very
limited, we can't go out,
we can't make a lot of
plans, 'cause we're either
gonna be at home, we're
gonna order takeout,
and we're gonna go to the beach,
and I'm not gonna put any timetable,
or we're not gonna make any big plans
that require being
anywhere at a certain time,
or anything like that,
and it was the most laid back
vacation I've ever been on
for that reason.
I didn't even make the kids
get up at a certain time,
oh, we gotta get on the beach,
we gotta get parking space,
or we're gonna be so far away
I'm gonna have to tote
everything for everybody,
I'm gonna have to make
two trips, three trips,
all the stuff I get worked up about.
You know, it wasn't an
issue, there was parking.
Yeah.
So it was definitely the
most laid back vacation,
I think, and having
those lower expectations
really helped bring me
to what I said, a seven,
but I did have an injury.
I mean, I was like, I'm gonna
eat all the foods I wanna eat,
I'm gonna bring my Ben and Jerry's,
like Christy's got this
Ben and Jerry's stash, man.
Even before we got to the
beach, like we brought a cooler
to make sure we had it.
So like, of course we're
watching some Survivor,
once the Neals start,
the Neals don't stop.
Right, still on Survivor...
Like season after season
after season, back to back,
we're just watching
it, 'cause, I told you,
you should've started
earlier and watched em all,
but no, you're the McLaughlin.
And I'm gonna tell you about that.
You do it different. And I'm
like, tonight's the night,
I'm pulling out the Ben and Jerry's
and I hurt myself eating ice cream.
I mean, I'm talking blood.
Oh, did you bite your freaking lip?
I didn't get so excited that
I started biting my tongue,
and my cheek and my lip
and that stuff that I do,
I didn't do any of that.
I ate the whole ice cream,
and man, it was so good,
and Christy was like...
What flavor are you talking about?
Tonight Dough.
Do you only get Tonight Dough?
Well, the number one on our taste test...
By the way, you gotta
get that at Target only.
Yeah, I can't find it.
So I'm enjoying it,
Christy's like how much of
that, 'cause I got the pint,
how much of that have you eaten?
And I showed it to her
and it was half gone,
I was like, I'm stopping
right here halfway,
but this is my pint.
There's another pint of
the same stuff in there
that y'all can share, and
there's some stuff that
I don't like that y'all can
have, but this is my pint,
and I'm eating out of it.
One pint for the week?
I mean that's not going that hard.
I also ate out of some of theirs.
'Cause when you talk about
I'm gonna eat whatever I want,
I mean, for me that would
be half a pint a night.
Yeah, I was eating lots of pizza,
lots of Mexican food, lots of...
I gained three pounds.
Interesting.
Like I actually did, yeah.
I weighed.
'Cause I'm pretty consistent in my weight,
but anyway, so I'm eating ice cream,
I'm enjoying it,
and when it's done,
my mouth, which was very cold,
all of a sudden I realized
like my lip is hurting,
and then I look down
and there's like some blood on
my freaking Ben and Jerry's.
Well that's definitely yours.
I hope it is.
Don't share that with anybody.
Yeah.
The bloody Ben and Jerry's is dad's.
And I'm taking the last
bite out of my mouth
and I'm realizing...
I'm eating with a knife,
I've been eating with a
knife this whole time.
I have, I think this is worse,
I cut my lip with a spoon.
I was like, I've cut my
mouth with the spoon.
Only Link Neal is capable of this.
I mean right here on the side of my mouth,
it was bleeding.
A man can cut himself with a spoon.
I had cut...
Gather round, one dollar
to see the man who
can cut himself with a spoon.
Not only once.
Step right up.
Two places.
But how?
Well...
It was a sharp spoon.
I'll say, yeah it was a sharp spoon.
The edge of the spoon was sharp.
Christy was like, oh
yes, sometimes you know,
spoon goes down in the garbage disposal.
Gets sharp.
And like it'll whack
the edge a little bit,
and I think that's what happened.
So when I would pull the
spoon out of my mouth,
it would slice the edge of like
where my lips come together
on the left side of my cheek.
Why are you putting it so far to the side?
I'm just getting every
last bit of ice cream out.
And I sliced...
I heard people could eat with a spoon
and you would be the one that
would cut yourself with it.
Two slices, and it wasn't
just bleeding a little bit,
brother, it was bleeding a lot.
The mouth has a lot of capillaries.
I mean, I had to run in there,
I mean, I was like, man, am I gonna faint?
I'm not gonna faint, I'm not gonna faint.
I just grabbed a paper towel,
I rolled it up like a cigar
and I put it in the edge
of my mouth like gauze, and
then we finished Survivor.
We finished Survivor.
We had to pause it for dad to save himself
from the killer spoon.
Yeah, so, I mean...
But you could still surf.
Probably would have had
eight if it wasn't for that.
You could still surf
with that bloody mouth.
A lot more adventures to share,
but first, let's sell some merch.
I'm actually not wearing
the shirt that I want
to bring your attention to.
I don't even know if the
shirt that I'm wearing
is still available.
Cotton candy Randy.
Maybe it is, that's why you
gotta go to mythical.com,
but the shirt that I wanna tell you about,
that you may have seen me wear elsewhere
is the beans shirt.
It just says beans on it,
it's my favorite shirt.
It says established, does it say?
It says established in 1984,
beans were made in 1984
for the first time.
So there it's been corellated to fiction?
It says mythical, it says
beans and then I think
it says mythical, established 1984.
Okay, yeah, it's a cool shirt.
Yeah, it's just gray with blue lettering,
you know?
Beans.
I like it, I like a good gray shirt.
Lots of things besides shirts.
Most of my shirts, if I'm
gonna go to a t-shirt,
it's gonna be a gray one.
I mean, I got so many gray things.
It's just great.
But if you have a gray
shirt, you can't be the guy
that wears gray shorts,
'cause then you just look like
you're in a uniform.
I don't like gray shorts.
No, I thought about this
'cause I love gray things,
and I have gray shoes.
You've thought about this.
And I have gray hats, and I have gray...
Yeah, and the contrasting shorts.
Shirts, but I don't have gray shorts.
Maybe I should switch it up,
go gray shorts, black shirt.
Nope, mythical.com, get your beans shirt.
Well, okay, so I said four,
but I wanna talk about some of the,
I wanna talk about what
I think was the highlight
for me, because some good
things happened, right?
My mouth got better.
The next morning, when I
woke up, my mouth was better.
Very quickly, because
of all the blood flow,
that's why it bleeds, that's why it heals.
But let me tell ya, I
inspected all them spoons
before I went back into...
Yeah, you gotta throw
those sharp spoons out,
or just put em down the garbage disposal.
Well, we washed it, I put it back in,
I didn't feel good about throwing it away.
Put a warning on it.
Yeah, I feel bad about that now.
So, another of my expectations,
and maybe this sends it up beyond a four,
now that I think about it,
cause I was kinda just
thinking about me, selfishly.
Again, I had an expectation
that the kids would
learn how to surf, right?
Shepard never has surfed,
he's been on the paddle board
with me, but he has
never surfed by himself,
and Locke had been a couple
weeks before the vacation,
and surfed near San Diego
and had a good time.
But the first couple of times,
we just went out with me and
Locke and Locke's friend,
who's staying with us.
Chore boy.
Yeah, the one who just agrees,
he carries everything for us .
He doesn't, and it was really cool,
'cause first of all,
Locke is better than me
at regular surfing already.
That's not saying much.
Which, by that, I mean
his ability to pop up
when he catches a wave
and actually surf it in,
I'm not saying that he's like
turning and like all that,
but he's an athletic
kid, and just immediately
just got it and popped up
and was riding these waves in
and was having an incredible time,
and was like motivated to go
out with me in the morning.
Oh, that's cool.
So, and that was something
that we can do together,
which he's like, when are we going again?
Like now that we're back at home.
So that was super cool to
see him kinda catch something
like that, and then we had one wetsuit
that was a little bit too big for Shepard
and a little bit too
small for Locke's friend
and so they would use
this, they would share it,
so we couldn't go at the same time,
and Shepard, speaking of sleeping late,
I mean Shepard, that boy
would sleep till one o'clock.
Oh wow.
I think my older kids can do that.
And so...
Lando's at 10, he will not do that.
It will change soon.
Good.
So, 'cause I mean, this has been
like the last year or so for Shepard,
as he's like becoming,
he's about to turn 12.
But I was like, okay, Shepard,
we're gonna go surfing,
now I hurt my back on day two,
still had not taken Shepard surfing,
but the next day, I was like, okay
well I can't surf, but I
can take you out there,
so me and Shepard got up, we go out there,
and I got my wetsuit on,
and I'm like, I'm just gonna do the things
that I've seen other
like surf instructors do,
which is like, what you said,
all right, we're gonna get on shore,
we're gonna put the board on the beach,
I'm gonna show him how to pop up, right?
Okay, he gets that pretty quickly.
Gonna go out there,
they can't really paddle yet enough
to kind of get themselves in a wave,
so you push them into a wave.
Yeah.
So I go out there and
literally like the second wave
that he tried, I push him into the wave,
he stands up, rides it
all the way into the sand.
Yeah, he's so light, and he's athletic,
and he's fearless.
Yeah, he's not scared of anything.
But being that light helps a lot.
Oh yeah, if I could just have
started at that age, man.
God, start now.
Learn how to do things, all
you 12 year olds listening,
no, no, I'm saying, any
sport where your distance
from said thing that you're
supposed to like be on,
like surfboards, skis, snowboard.
Golf?
Golf.
Your distance from the thing.
The green, you're on the green.
Well, no, your distance
from the ball is like,
the taller you get, trust me, I'm tall,
the harder it's gonna get.
You wanna start early.
Start short.
And stay short, start short, stay short.
Smoke cigarettes and you won't grow.
Oh gosh.
But that was a proud dad
moment to like see him,
and then to be like, oh, he wants more,
he's back out, he's got
this huge smile on his face,
push him into some more waves.
And I said, all right, Shepard,
you're on your own, man.
I'm not gonna push you now.
I'm gonna go in, I'm
gonna sit on the beach
and I'm gonna watch you.
I go in to the beach.
Maybe take a nap.
And I'm watching him,
and he just catches a wave by himself.
And then he goes back out,
and like, when you're
learning how to surf,
you kinda start in the white water area.
Yeah.
But the next time he just goes out
and he just paddles past that
and paddles all the way out
with all the other surfers.
And I'm like, okay, I don't
know how this is gonna go.
He didn't catch any waves
while he was out there,
but boy, he tried for like half an hour.
Wow, it's nice when they get
motivated, self motivated.
Yeah, and that's the thing,
he's likes to play video
games, he's really motivated
to do that, but he's done
a lot of different things,
but he hasn't been like, oh,
this is the thing I'm gonna do
and I'm super self motivated to do it,
so it was really cool to see him do it
and again, it was one of
those things where it's like,
this is really cool, I just
watched him learn how to surf,
and now he's motivated to do it,
and the rest of the week
he went out with us,
and ended up catching more waves.
So while I selfishly wanted to be surfing
and learning to surf myself,
it was cool to see both of the kids
kinda take to it,
and now it's something
that we can do together,
which, sitting out there on the beach,
I was like, I'm a dad,
and I just did that.
Well, doesn't sound like you did much,
but you did enough.
That's the thing, you don't
really have to do much.
Yeah, that's the illusion.
It's actually teaching a kid to surf,
versus teaching a kid how to ride a bike,
oh, ride a bike, that'll
make you wanna kill your kid.
Surfing, totally different
ball game, super easy.
Well, it depends, I
mean, I took Lando out,
I mean, he's more cautious,
I'm not gonna say timid,
I'll just say cautious, and
I say, hey, we're gonna ride
this surfboard like a boogie board,
we're gonna get you on
this thing, get you going,
and the first one, I always do this,
I got a little...
Too aggressive.
Too aggressive, and I went out too far,
and then the wave was a little too big,
and I said, stay, you're on
the right place on the board,
maybe you need to come
back a little bit further,
then you don't want the nose to dive in.
And I pushed him on that
wave when we got out there,
and he just like, it was chaos.
And then he comes up, and
of course, I grab the board,
so the board doesn't hit
him or something like that
and I'm like, all right,
let's go back out,
and he's immediately going in,
but I have the board,
and the board...
Is tethered to him.
Is tethered to his ankle.
Right, that's how you catch him.
And low dad moment for me
was continuing to go out.
Drag his butt out there.
I was like, we'll do this differently,
it was my fault, well,
I screwed up, you know,
I got over aggressive and
then my response is where
I really screwed up,
I was like, no, you're not giving up,
you're not giving up, and
of course he couldn't go,
I wasn't dragging him
out, I stayed in place,
and he realized that he couldn't go in.
I was like you're not giving up,
we're gonna do this
together, and he was upset,
and he won, and we went back in,
and he went and like
basically told Christy
how big of an asshole I was,
and you know what?
Totally true, but it was just,
I wanted it for him so badly.
Right.
That I was doing it for me, not for him.
And especially when it didn't work out,
then I wasn't being sensitive at all,
and I feel horrible about it,
and so I took a few
minutes to process that,
and I was like, hey, and I apologized,
I looked him in the eyes,
and I'm like, I didn't do that right,
I want you to try again,
but I know you like things
to be explained to you so that
you can know what to expect
and I didn't do that, and
so I was like, basically,
let's have a do over.
And you know what?
After a few minutes, he was like...
Oh the same day?
Let's try it.
So yeah, like 20 minutes
later we went back out,
and I did it the right
way, and by the end of it,
he was like maybe I'll
try to get up on my knees
or something, but it was
a positive experience.
And it was better than
being on a boogie board,
cause you go so much further
when you're as light as he is.
I think I had forgotten about
that until I just told you,
cause that was kind of the
low point of the vacation,
cause the low point that I remembered
was the point where I got angry,
that I wasn't referring to that,
so I guess there were two of them.
We pack everything up
from the beach, and like
I had to take the boards back up,
and I'm in charge of the biggest stuff
'cause we gotta go up these
long steps up the side
of this cliff to get back to the car.
Right, right.
And the goal is still
everybody pull your weight
so that we only have to make one trip.
Right.
And I got the big stuff,
and so we get back up there,
we get everything loaded in,
everybody's pulling their
weight, everything's going good.
Somebody left something.
We get back home, and I
take my sunglasses off
at the house, and I'm reaching
for my regular glasses,
and I'm like, where are my glasses?
And I'm saying this to Christy.
In the Pacific Ocean.
I'm like where are my glasses?
She was looking at me
like why are you asking me
where your glasses are?
And I'm like, my glasses, I had a speaker,
the speaker had a case, cause
I didn't have a glasses case,
I took the speaker out, 'cause
we were playing the speaker
on the beach, and I put
my glasses in that case.
And then you guys packed everything up.
It's their fault.
So that I could get...
It's not your fault.
The big stuff back up there,
so did anybody see my glasses?
It's like why are you asking me?
I'm like, well, because
you guys are the ones
who packed everything up.
Right.
And cause we're back at the house now,
we've driven the, I don't know,
10 minutes back or whatever.
And so, I'm mad.
I'm very mad.
I'm like, I need my glasses to see,
I have contacts, I have
enough contacts to last
the rest of the week, I
could just be no glasses man.
But you need the glasses.
But who's Link without glasses?
It's like, I bought a
second pair of my glasses.
Well, there you go.
Identical to my current pair
so that if something happened to em,
I would have em to be Link.
Yeah.
I'm the guy, I'm the one with the glasses.
Well, don't be so attached to it,
I mean, I'm getting older by the second.
Right, I mean, I'm the one
with the gray hair and glasses.
You're currently the one with glasses.
The only one with glasses.
But those glasses, my back
up glasses were stolen
two years ago from my car
in my own freaking driveway.
Oh man.
Screw you, person who did that.
They're prescription, you
can't use them anyway.
Yeah, jackass.
And I never got em replaced
because they're expensive.
Did they steal anything else?
Some sunglasses.
Christy's sunglasses.
Those are prescription...
Not my sunglasses.
So, I'm mad, I'm like,
they gotta be on the beach,
so I go back, I drive
back, and I'm just so mad,
I'm like this is not vacation.
And then I had to find a place to park.
But did anybody say something like,
oh yeah, I did not grab that?
Well like, he was like here's the speaker,
the speaker was in the
case, they put the speaker
back in the case.
And the glasses were not...
So, I was like, they
didn't care about my stuff
when they were packing it up,
I trust my family to care
about everybody's stuff
when they're packing it up.
Not just my stuff.
That's where you were wrong,
yeah, you can't trust your family.
I had to find a place to
park, I'm putting on a mask,
I'm running down all these steps,
trying not to break my neck,
I get down there, and
the tide comes in so far.
All the way to the cliffs.
All the way to the cliffs?
If you leave anything on
the beach, yeah, it's gone.
Well, or almost, I get down there
and I run back to the spot, and I'm like,
I'm exasperated because the tide's,
literally the tide is
coming over the place where
we had set up.
No one else was there, and I'm like,
I'm looking around, and
I look to the right,
like looking to the ocean,
you're not gonna believe this.
My glasses were floating
away in the ocean.
You're joking.
Yeah, I'm joking.
My glasses weren't there at all.
I was so mad.
They had already been taken.
But I had this vision.
The ocean had taken them?
I had a vision that my glasses,
that that's what was gonna happen,
I was gonna get there just in time,
even though so much time had elapsed.
Your glasses float?
Glasses don't float.
Well some do, the floating ones.
In the ocean they don't float.
They're more buoyant in the ocean.
I don't, one time I
forgot I had on sunglasses
and I went back into the
ocean 'cause I was hot
and I dipped my head totally in the water,
and when I came up, it was a lot brighter,
and I realized that I had
just lost my sunglasses
right there, one second ago.
You'll never find em.
And I instinctively
reached down, gone forever.
Those are my green sunglasses
that people post on Twitter,
when I look like I'm like smiling
real big like I'm the sun,
and I'm wearing those glasses.
You can probably get a
replacement for those.
I miss those freaking glasses.
You know those two little inner tubes
that go around the glasses right there,
those little donut inner tubes,
we should sell those.
Like wings, like swimming wings,
and then they hook the cords
which go behind your head,
and you're just like a dad golfer.
You don't even have to do that.
Yeah, cause they'll float, let em go.
But you know what, they do make a thing
that is a floaty football
sized, football shaped thing
for your keys that you
could attach to glasses too.
Like boat keys?
Boat keys.
So, I asked the people,
you know, you hate having to
ask the people on the beach,
hey did you happen to see some glasses?
Yeah.
No, they didn't.
I make this walk of
shame back up the stairs,
I sit in the car, and I'm
like, I don't wanna drive home.
I'm just, I'm so mad at them.
'Cause you can't see.
'Cause they don't even care.
Right, can't even see my way home.
Well, I had my sunglasses
on, they're prescription.
And then I was like, dang it,
I remember taking those glasses
and putting them in the
case, and then I was like,
but I think they were my sunglasses,
and I think my regular glasses
are in my sunglasses case,
right here in the console of
the car, and I opened it up.
And there they were.
Took out my sunglasses case,
and they just laughed in my face.
I mean, I've never seen
glasses laugh at a person,
but I felt it, it's like .
But that's a beautiful
moment when you find a thing
that you thought that you lost.
I mean, you feel stupid
for having trekked down
to the beach.
Well, I was so convinced
that it was my family
who collectively did this,
so I came home and told them
the same story I told you,
except I stopped at
the part where I got em
out of the ocean.
Yeah, I was about to say, man,
there's no reason they
have to know what happened.
No, I told them the truth, I mean,
see that's the thing, it's
not about being perfect,
it's about being penitent.
And I'm glad that Lando responded to that
and, I mean, Christy was
like, now you need to tell
the whole story if you're
gonna tell that story.
Yeah, that always happens
when I lose something.
And I've actually learned at this point
to not just immediately try
to find a family member,
that's one of the great
things about having family
is that you've got that many
more people to blame things on.
Yeah.
But, it's always a losing game, you know?
It's always a losing game.
It's not fun even if it is their fault
to blame stuff on people.
But when you lose stuff,
it's almost always
your own fault.
The superpower that Christy has is
I've been looking, I've
been tracing my steps,
I've been thinking so hard,
I've been looking for the thing
and it's like, oh!
And then she's like, here it is.
You know, what is that superpower?
It's just like, and then that trains you
to not look, because if
she can magically find it
well, I'm not gonna waste
time looking for something
that you can magically find.
And I'll tell her that.
Right, I doubt that it's magic.
But it doesn't work that way,
the magic only works if
you've exasperated yourself
to the point of exhaustion
and frustration.
It helps if you don't blame anybody,
because the magic doesn't
work if you blame,
if I blame Christy,
her magic doesn't work,
and if I don't look
but if I put in the effort
and then I get exasperated
and I go to her, oh baby, I need you,
baby, I can't find my glasses.
That's what it takes.
I know I put em in the wrong place
but can you work your magic?
Then it'll work.
What you wanna do is you
wanna enlist the help
of your family without blaming them.
We're talking about
bounty, that's the only way
my family's gonna get involved, my kids.
You can have my bloody ice
cream if you find my glasses?
Yeah, iron, it's higher iron content.
The other thing that happened to me,
speaking of watching television,
as you've watched Survivor.
Still love it.
Now, I'm sure you suffer
from a similar thing.
No, don't be sure.
A lot of people struggle
with the whole aspect
of not doing, right?
So even while on vacation,
I'm still thinking about
accomplishing something, it might be, oh,
you're gonna learn how
to surf properly, and
I think that going back
to the enneagram one and
the enneagram three, there's
a lot of similarities
in the way that we approach things.
You might want to make sure your vacation
goes perfectly, and I might want to...
Unlock an achievement.
Accomplish something on my vacation,
but they manifest themselves
in pretty similar ways
a lot of the times,
so for me, and this is a
common workaholic problem,
I feel it's very difficult
for me to enjoy a vacation
because I feel worthless if
I look at a day on vacation
and I'm like, you didn't do anything,
like you didn't learn how to do anything,
you didn't like achieve something.
Like cause even doing something
like having a good time
is achieving something.
If you just sort of laid there,
you kinda got up late, and
then you watched a lot of
television, and then dinner rolled around,
and like my wife is really good
at just sort of embracing
that and enjoying that
and being able to just be,
and that being something
that is fun and enjoyable,
whereas I just develop
this sense of worthlessness
and like I have no value,
because again, my tendency
is to attach my value
to my accomplishments,
something that I'm unraveling
like a giant knot.
Yeah.
Since I've been in therapy.
I've had that problem a lot,
just with COVID, in terms of work,
because we're hamstrung in a lot of ways
in terms of what we can do
and like what we're working
on that leads to stuff.
Well, and that's another
thing that happens to me
when I go on vacation.
Not only am I thinking well
you're gonna learn to surf,
but I also think that like,
oh, you're also going to have
this thought about some
project that we're working on.
You're gonna have a breakthrough,
you're gonna come up with a new idea,
you're gonna write a song,
like, I had this secret hope
and because of my personality,
many times that's what
vacation is filled with.
It's oh, I wrote two songs, or, you know,
it's I came up with an idea,
I did this little write up,
and I do that in part because that's where
I get my self worth, right?
So, I mean, it's good if you're
trying to be an entertainer,
but it's also bad.
I'll veg out over here,
you keep going with that.
And but it's bad for
your own mental health.
So, but one of the things
that I found myself doing,
especially after I got hurt
is, I talked a lot about how
Jesse and I had watched
Married at First Sight,
talked about that a few podcasts ago.
You turned a lot of people onto that,
and it's...
Yeah, you're welcome.
I don't know, I don't know.
And well, you're definitely
not gonna know about this,
so the thing now, my
wife and I, let me say,
my wife watches a lot
of trashy reality TV,
and she has roped me into it,
and I fall for it hook, line, and sinker,
even if I am trying to resist it.
And the thing that we
ended up getting into,
which this is even more popular
than Married at First Sight,
is we started watching 90 Day
Fiance Before the 90 Days.
And I guess this is
the most recent season.
Now you've seen this guy, Ed,
you may not know that he is Ed,
but if I showed you a picture of Ed,
you'd be like, oh, that's
the guy from all the memes
over the past couple months.
Oh, okay.
And...
I can barely say what 90 Day Fiance is.
90 Day Fiance is a show about people
who are, there's one
person who's in the US,
and then one person who
is in a foreign country,
and they are getting married
in order for the person
to get a green card.
Oh, this is the thing that the only,
Lincoln was watching
Pewdiepie watch one of these.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's super popular.
So I watched it with him,
that's the only way I've seen the show,
and Felix watched it, I told you this,
he watched the episode
segments out of order,
and he cared so little
that he didn't even,
he was like, oh, I'm
watching these out of order,
the story was out of order,
like they got engaged,
it was, but which I found hilarious.
But there's like five
different versions of the show,
cause there's 90 Day
Fiance, but then there's
90 Fiance Before the 90 Days.
So Before the 90 Days is a different show?
So this is them meeting the people
who they might have then gotten engaged to
and then the 90 Day Fiance is like
after they've gotten engaged,
and is it gonna work out.
So I don't even know how old this is,
but it's the same people
that I've seen in the memes.
So it's relatively recent.
So they shot, they documented them meeting
for the first time and dating basically
before they got engaged?
Yeah.
But they didn't air any of that,
so they had a spin off show
because they had so much footage
that it was like a prequel?
It's absolutely incredible.
Now, you have to be a
certain kind of personality,
but based on the popularity of the show,
and what I see on the internet,
there's a lot of people who
fit this personality type
that get drawn into this kind of thing.
It's the same reason I watch the Bachelor,
or anything like that.
You just can't believe
that people are capable
of this type of behavior,
and you just keep watching it
and I know that there's
some sort of thing going on
that's just like, I feel
like by watching these people
be themselves, it makes me
almost feel, it makes me feel
separated and a little bit sane,
it's like, I would never do that.
So it makes you feel good,
because you're kind of
separating yourself from
the actions of these people.
As opposed to it making
you angry and frustrated
that they're like making dumb decisions?
It makes me angry and frustrated,
but I'm more blown away.
Okay, if you're gonna watch
90 Day Fiance Before the 90 Days,
spoiler, I'm gonna spoil some
things, so just spoiler alert.
Okay, so first of all,
there's Ed and there's Rose, all right?
And Ed is like this 55 year
old dude from San Diego,
who has a very, I'll just
say his look is very distinct
and that's why he's kind of
become popular in these memes.
Okay.
And then Rose is like a
20 something year old,
like 23 years old from the Philippines,
and their relationship is bonkers,
but very entertaining.
Are you looking him up?
Ed and Rose, Rosemary?
Yeah, and Rosemary.
So, you know that guy.
Oh yeah, oh.
He's in everything, right?
And he's like,
there's a famous scene
where he like sits down
next to her in the pool and he's like,
you're my, he's like, you're my vision.
I can't remember what it is,
it's just a bunch of memes,
cause the things that he says,
and then the way that she talks to him,
back to him is just phenomenal.
Now, she's younger than his daughter.
He's got slick, he's a large man...
Yeah.
With slicked back hair
and like he's never clean shaven,
and yeah, his head just kinda
goes into his shoulders.
Right, and I think that's
why he's got a very distinct
physicality that people have locked into.
Okay.
Now, let me tell you about
this other guy, okay?
Oh, another guy.
This is the think that kept me,
and the freaking TLC
producers, they're so good,
cause let me just say,
each one of these episodes
is an hour and 40 minutes long.
What?
I think that's right.
This is the rejected, this
is the prequel footage?
I'm watching this on, I think TLC.com,
I don't know, Jesse's doing it,
there's this on the Apple TV.
I'm sitting through, there's commercials,
I'm watching commercials,
there's six commercials
in a commercial break.
Oh, you watch commercials?
There's no way, you can't,
if you wanna, I guess there's maybe,
unless you wanna buy the season
on Amazon, I don't know how,
I'm just trying to give you
a picture of just how much
I had succumbed to reality TV.
I'm watching commercials again,
I'm buying things that
I'm seeing, you know?
A swiffer.
No you didn't.
No, I didn't.
But you thought about it.
But it's gone in my
brain, I'll tell you that.
I'm gonna buy it at some point.
Somebody just heard you say it, and...
The ads are working.
And increase the chances.
Hey, advertising works, if
it doesn't then me and you
are gonna be broke.
In trouble.
So let me just, so there was one day
where we watched, I don't
know how many episodes
back to back, but I guaran-damn-tee you
it was seven hours of the show.
I've never watched this much television
in one sitting.
And I was taking breaks and like eating,
but I kept coming freaking back,
and we didn't even pause it.
We would go downstairs and do something,
it would just keep rolling,
cause you don't really have
to follow that closely.
But the story that I
could not escape from.
Can I ask you something?
You can ask me anything you want.
At hour one.
I hated myself at minute seven.
You don't understand, I
hated myself the whole time.
But did you know you were
like, oh, this is happening,
we're doing this.
I actually thought to myself,
I told Jesse this like five hours in,
I was like,
this is, and I'm not making light of this,
I was like this is what it feels like
to be addicted to drugs.
Oh gosh.
Because I was like, you can imagine
that like you keep going
back to this thing,
and you know that it's not good for you,
and you don't even really like it,
but you can't stop.
I was like, I have a whole lot of empathy
for people who are addicted
to drugs right now.
I'm addicted to TLC.
Hold on.
And I'm about to tell you why.
Is it because you wanted
to find out what happens?
Yes.
Okay.
Well, I mean, they got
engaged, that's what happens.
It's before the 90 Days.
Dude, you don't even,
I'm about to blow your mind.
You know what's going to happen.
You don't, you don't, especially
in one particular case,
right?
So there's all kinds of
things, like there's one woman
who is basically being
catfished by this dude,
and you know, as the viewer,
that she's being catfished.
You know that this dude's not real,
but she's so convinced that,
and you can't stop watching
someone in their delusion,
and it's kinda sad because
I know that the producers
and everyone knows that this
person is in a delusion,
and it's like you remember the famous...
They didn't tell her?
There's a famous photograph,
from an ethical standpoint,
there's multiple photographs
of like really difficult things
to see, like a child who's starving,
or somebody who's been injured,
and there's a person
who takes a photograph,
and there's like this journalistic ethic,
which is like I don't
intervene, I just observe.
And then people find out,
oh you took this picture,
but you didn't help this kid, or whatever?
There's a certain aspect
to it where you're like,
you kinda wanna just be like, you know,
hey, this isn't real, but
you know that the producers
understand letting them
live out their delusion
is this intensely entertaining thing
that you can't stop watching.
Now, one particular
delusion that is, I think,
the key reason I kept going back,
there's a dude named, I know
we're going a little bit long,
but I've gotta tell you this.
You know what, there is no perfect length.
Right.
There's nothing to, you know what?
Maybe you don't need to tell the story
because you feel like you need to achieve
the end of this video.
No, no, no, you have gotta hear this.
So, there's a guy named
David, who is from Las Vegas.
Okay.
He's in his 50's I believe,
maybe, let's just say that.
He might be 60, I don't know.
This guy goes to these dating services,
online dating services, where it's a site
where these Russian women,
and I think maybe in this case
it was a Ukrainian woman,
they're on the site, and
you see a picture of them,
and you can begin chatting with them.
Not video chat, text chat only.
Okay.
And you know that, do they
basically want to come
to America?
Well, hold your horses.
Okay.
Stay in the Ukraine for a second.
So you text chat with this person,
who, by the way, does not speak English,
and so everything that you're
saying is being translated
into Ukrainian I guess, and vice versa.
So there's a language barrier,
but it's sort of overcome
by this text tool.
Yeah.
And you pay by the minute.
This guy, first of all, it
comes to light, that again,
spoiler, it comes to light
that he's been chatting up
lots of women over the years,
and that this is basically the extent
of his adult relationships,
at least for the past 10, 15 years.
Oh.
And this one woman, Lana is her name.
Now, Lana's not making any of the money
that he's paying for the phone call?
She gets paid, yeah she is.
Oh, she gets paid to talk to him?
Well, she gets paid by the site.
Oh.
Why would she do it if
she's not getting paid?
To find a date.
No, no, no, no, no, no, this is her job,
her job is to go on this site
and to talk to multitudes
of men who want to chat with
the pretty blonde Russian lady.
Oh, oh, okay, so it's
like, but it's not just,
it doesn't have to be, it's like a,
what was that, it's like the sex line.
Yeah, but you're text chatting.
But it's not just about
the sex, it's just talk.
Let me just say a couple of things.
I thought it was just a dating line,
but it's not, it's a service, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, he's paying
half a million dollars.
Oh gosh.
Over the course of the years.
Okay.
To chat with these women,
and for seven years he's been chatting.
Now, first of all, he's never seen,
he's just seen the
picture and then chatted.
So everyone watching knows that this woman
is almost assuredly not the person
that he is talking to, right?
It's just some dude named Boris,
who's talking back to him,
right?
Could be AI.
But he is convinced that
they are in a relationship.
He considers her his girlfriend,
because that's what she does on the,
she acts as if she's in a
relationship with him, right?
So for seven years this goes on.
Now, over the course of this seven years,
and this is all before we're seeing it.
He has been to, I don't know if, again,
I know that Ukraine is not Russia.
I don't know which one he went to,
I think maybe he went to the Ukraine,
I'll just say that,
three times to meet her.
And every single time he has met her,
she's come up with an excuse.
Now let me explain.
He only communicates with
her through the service,
even when he's going to
meet her in the Ukraine.
And so he'll be like, why
can't I just get your number,
and she gets mad, and she's
like, only through the chat,
only through the thing.
So he's paying her to
arrange a meeting with her
and every time he goes over
there, paying on his own dime,
she's not there, cause an excuse comes up.
My brother died, or what,
like she's got all kinds of excuses,
and we know, the producers
know, the audience knows
this guy is in the depths of a delusion.
It's sad, but you're like,
how far is he gonna go?
Because when we're watching the show,
he's talking to her and
he's like, I'm going back,
I'm going back over there
and I'm gonna meet her,
and this time she's gonna
be at this train station
or whatever, so you see him go over there.
This was the first time
cameras followed him over?
Yeah, but you see him talk,
like his friends try to
have interventions with him
like oh, we're gonna get a shot
of you and your two friends
at this bar and you're
talking and it's like,
David, I really think this is a scam,
and he's like, I don't
believe it's a scam.
And he has this weird sort of robotic way
of approaching it,
where he's not gonna
listen to reason, right?
So other people have tried to intervene.
Multiple people, his friends,
and even a Russian lady.
Okay, that helps the
producers' case a little bit.
A Russian lady who was on
the services that he met
at one time is telling
him that this is a scam
and he meets her when he goes over there.
Oh.
And she since got
married to somebody else,
and she's out of the game now,
but so he goes back over
there for a fourth time,
of course she doesn't show up.
He comes back home, and then, you know,
a couple hours later,
I'm still in the bed,
I'm still watching this,
he's going back again.
Why are you doing,
I can't believe you're watching this.
I'm also following like five other couples
at the same time,
but I just, this one in particular,
I was like, I just
don't, how is it possible
that he's going there for the fifth time?
And then he's like, okay,
she's supposed to be there
at 11 o'clock, he's
still never talked to her
through anything but the chat.
Yup.
And this very distinct blonde woman.
Spoiler alert, don't listen
to what I'm about to say
if you want to enjoy this yourself.
She's there.
What?
The woman from the pictures shows up
and hugs him.
And I'm just like, having
invested so much time into this,
and feeling so worthless,
it was like another hit.
What?
It was all of a sudden like
ah, this was all worth it.
What, but hold on, she was an actress?
No.
They just brought in.
So many things were going through my mind,
I was like, did the
TLC producers like find
this woman from the pictures and say, hey,
will you act like it
was you this whole time?
Yeah, this will make his day.
It was her.
But when they interviewed
her, it was very clear
that she was continuing to carry on,
she wants the money, she
wants the gifts from him,
and it seems that she wants
the ability to come to the US.
I think, at this point,
where I stopped watching
the show was the tell all,
which was like during COVID,
where they're all on video chat.
Oh wow.
So like after the after the 90 Days,
she didn't even show up for that.
And he was like, I haven't
spoken to her in six days,
I think the engagement,
they got engaged.
They got engaged?
And I was just like...
So she's also maybe an addict too.
Like whatever he's giving her.
She's addicted to money, man.
Okay.
But it was, I had to follow this story.
And that becomes a 90 Day Fiance episode?
I guess.
But it was so, like I don't
know what the moral of it is,
I mean, for me...
It's tough.
For me it's just like
I can't let this happen
unless I'm on vacation, right?
I feel worthless, I hate
myself for doing this,
I don't know why I'm so
invested in finding out
if this woman's real.
I don't know what's gonna
happen with Ed and Rose,
I mean, Ed told Rose that
she needed to shave her legs
and that she had bad
breath, and it's like,
I don't like the way
that he told her that.
But how's she gonna
respond, and then like oh,
is what's her name gonna
find out that Williams is not
a real dude, that she's being catfished?
Like you find yourself
so invested in this.
Moral of the story for
David though, I think, is
if you have a delusion, just follow it
to the end of the yellow brick road.
You're probably right.
It may come true.
Now listen, I'm not shutting this down,
cause I got...
Questions.
I'm flooded.
You should just watch it.
I'm flooded with memories
associated with this, so.
Hold on, you've been
talking to a Ukrainian woman
?
I don't care if this goes,
you know what, this may be a part two.
Don't .
Let's just blow it open.
Every time you get so invested
in a freaking trash show
it becomes an episode.
I think I need my own podcast
where I just talk about
reality TV, can we do that?
Well, am I not invited?
I mean...
Somebody's gotta tell
you you have a problem
and that you just can't give in to this.
See, you need to take a breath.
No, but if I can make money off of it,
then I start to feel
like I'm worth something.
Like if I could take my addiction
to TLC and other things like it
and turn it into a paying project,
then I'll say, oh this, okay, that's good,
this makes sense.
It validates your addiction.
Spending seven hours,
I mean this is like
those people who sit down
and watch all three of Lord of the Rings
back to back to back, which,
I'm just not that kind
of person.
I cannot do that.
But it's not, because...
It's not Lord of the Rings.
Yeah, it's a...
It's far from it.
It's real people that
have been just marionetted
through producing and editing
for you to feel sorry for them
or feel better about yourself,
all of this psychology
it could be troubling.
But it does remind me
when we started producing
Commercial Kings.
So we made the pilot.
Yeah.
With Revelly, we worked
with Todd, who brought us in
and produced that and we had a producer
who worked on Survivor actually,
shoot, his name is on
the tip of my tongue.
Fernando.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Fernando was the one who was,
we were filming the pilot
episode in the mountains of
Asheville, North Carolina,
and with Heavy Hill the Trash Man,
the garbage collector.
Yeah.
And then we had some downtime
and we hadn't talked
about it ahead of time
and all of a sudden, Fernando's like,
we wanna set up some OTF interviews.
We were like OTF?
On the fly interviews.
It's like you know in like
reality competition shows
and stuff like that they
have confession cams
or they'll be talking to a producer.
And we hadn't thought about this at all.
Hadn't thought about it at all
and he was like it may
not be part of the show,
but let's just do it.
And then we made a decision
he wanted us to do them individually,
we didn't feel good
about that, I remember.
But we did it.
I remember he set up a shot
of me standing in front of
Heavy Hill's shed, in his backyard,
where he had his pet mule back there.
Yeah, I remember this.
Then you had a little downtime
while he interviewed me.
I remember when he interviewed
you I was like watching,
I was like, I think he
interviewed you first.
I was like how's this gonna go?
And here we were, we
like to be in control.
It was our show, we were
producers on the show too.
Yeah, executive producers.
Executive producers,
and we were producing the
commercial within the show,
so it's like we had
our hands in all of it.
Yeah.
And it felt a little weird
being interviewed by Fernando, who like,
in one sense worked for us,
but then he was interviewing us,
documenting the process of
us making these commercials,
so like he would throw things at us
and we would talk about it,
and then they go,
and then that ended up
being cut into the episode.
But then when we went to,
all of that was a tangent by the way,
Oh, you're getting somewhere.
Well I guess we became,
that was where I started to feel like
we were actually...
Employed?
No, we were in a reality television show.
Commercial Kings was
the show documenting us
making a commercial, but we
never thought of it that way.
We thought of it as we
were producing a show
that shows how we make the commercials.
But what Fernando tried to
achieve was a level of detachment
from how we were gonna be presented.
And what we're processing
at the same time.
And let out process and
and our point of view
not just become editorial
but become something
that happened on screen.
And it's difficult when the
people that you're doing
that with are really self aware.
And also producing the show.
Yeah, meaning us, we're pretty self aware.
We're pretty good at separating ourselves.
So it's like when he'd ask us a question,
half the time we were thinking,
what is the best way
to answer this question
to be entertaining but
also connect the dots
so that in the edit room
we can tell the best story,
and that...
We would be way better at that now
than we were in 2011.
Oh yeah, we weren't good at it.
No, no.
But if we were to just let
go and trusted Fernando
and just answered his questions,
Which we would do now.
Where we understand how to be ourselves.
Yes.
A lot more than we did in the early days.
Like right now.
Yeah.
There's so many times
I wish we could go back
and do Commercial Kings again.
And I think that was a part of it.
It stuck in our crawl that
like we were doing these
on the fly interviews.
And that's the part of the
show I don't like watching,
I don't like watching those interviews.
In series though,
and this is what I was
originally getting to,
so it wasn't a tangent, a
continuation of my though.
In series, we worked with a
different production company,
we worked with Joke Productions.
Revelly, the company that
funded the show and sold it
and produced the pilot,
they basically said we need
to bring in somebody else
who does this day in and day out.
Yeah.
Who can do it on a tighter budget.
Joke Productions was Joke and Biagio,
they were a married couple,
and Joke is her name.
For some reason she's
like Belgian or something.
Yeah.
And so Joke doesn't mean
funny ha ha over there.
But it works well, translates well.
I made all that up, I
actually don't know why
they called her Joke.
That's her name.
Was that right?
Yeah.
It did mean funny ha ha in Belgium?
I don't think so, I
think it's just a name.
Okay, maybe I wasn't joking.
Sometimes I say things just
because they might be cool
to say, and then I realize
I'm accessing a memory
that I didn't know I had.
Oh, well that's part of life.
I remember the first
episode we shot with them
was Make me a Pro Wrestler.
That was the name of the
business we were doing
the commercial for.
We aired em all out of order.
The Heavy Hill pilot episode
aired somewhere in the middle.
The Make me a Pro
Wrestler didn't turn out,
it was a dynamic commercial,
it had all that action,
but it didn't have a hook
and it wasn't .
It didn't come together.
But we learnt how to be wrestlers
and you freaking, with
your back and everything,
suplexed me.
And it hurt my back, by the way.
Yeah it did.
But we tried to get the guy
who was called the hobo, right?
Yeah, right, his wrestling
persona was the hobo,
we interviewed them all
and we wanted to...
Brandon was his name?
Yeah.
And he, I think he's still
involved in wrestling
at some point.
He was up until recently
because our buddy, Seaver
who helped produce...
Buddy System.
Second season of Buddy System,
who was one of the
writers on Buddy System,
we were the show runners,
his son had a connection to the world
of sort of amateur pro wrestling,
and so we kinda kept up and
we actually talked about this moment,
when we tried to get hobo to...
Change his persona.
To the baby.
And we said, on camera,
we thought it would be entertaining,
it would be an entertaining beat to mess
with these people's personas
to make them more marketable,
and so on camera, it's like we knew,
okay the big moment is
when we tell Brandon...
To shave his head.
That he needs to shave his head.
He had really long hair.
It was his signature for the hobo.
And wear a diaper.
And he was just gonna be
a bald man with a diaper.
and I felt horrible about this
because that goes, I mean, in my mind,
that goes a step beyond
what they're doing on TLC.
TLC is like I'm gonna
let this person flounder
in their delusion, and I'm
gonna film it for entertainment.
And all of our commercials...
We were trying to manipulate...
Well, all of our commercials
that really took off,
it was taking things that were true
and things that came out,
that we worked out of the woodwork
to become all of those commercials.
You know, like Cullman Liquidation Debt,
Epic and Honest Mobile Home Commercial.
Everything that he says is
something that he told us,
and then we just scripted it out.
But then, Joke and Biagio
started to try and teach us
that it's not, you know,
we didn't go with this
doccy reality thing, we went with this
they made it more reality TV.
You gotta produce it.
We need to have an
entertaining beat in Act one.
You guys make a great
commercial, that's Act three,
they gotta get hooked in Act one.
There's gotta be some stakes.
In Act two, this is a comedy,
you gotta say some funny stuff,
and so putting these
people in these situations
where it's like they have to respond to
us telling a dude to shave his long hair,
and his beard, right?
Yeah, everything.
Yeah, cause he had hair like you do now,
and a beard.
Maybe he didn't have a beard actually.
He had long hair though.
Yeah, it was his hair.
And the moment on camera
when we were trying to get him to shave it
and he was getting really close to it,
I felt so horrible.
Yeah, it's was like we were criticizing
his creative choice to be the hobo,
but also...
I still feel like the
baby is a better persona.
And I still feel that honest.
Well, I think he was hurt a little bit
that he was like the hobo,
the thing that I've invested
myself in isn't good enough
and you're asking me too,
I've also invested in my hair,
I've grown out my hair,
and you want me shave it off to be a baby.
And the reason why we know this
is because they did on the fly interviews
where we weren't there
where they ask Brandon and
then, that's when we found out
that he was on the verge
of tears talking about
how he went home and he talked to him mom.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's a lot of us just
looking like assholes
in this podcast, but you
know what, it's the truth.
We were torn, but Daniel, who was our like
I think his title was like...
Director.
He came on as a creative consultant,
but then he basically became a director.
Yeah.
But that's a weird title for reality.
It's important though,
so it's a part of it.
I remember Daniel in the
corner, sitting on the floor
with his knees up on his chest,
and literally with his hands
in his hair.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, he was thinking.
Just almost pulling his hair out,
and he was on the verge of
tears, and he was like...
We can't make this .
We can't do this to this guy,
we can't do it, and we
were like, you're right.
And then like Joke, I mean, I love Joke,
it's like she was focused on the product
and she had the counterpoint,
since like guys...
He's just shaving his head.
It's his decision to do it.
It's not the end of the
world to wear a wig.
Yeah, we're not gonna make him do it.
He's not going permanently bald.
And all of this is good television,
it was her point of view.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
The fact that this is
stressing you out is why people
will wanna watch it.
But we didn't document that.
No, we didn't.
The story that we're telling now
is what should have been Commercial Kings.
Yes.
I think we should have
gone so much more raw,
and sincere.
And that would've been
the way to do the show
that didn't require
this overproduction too.
Because our on the fly interviews,
the reason why you hate
them and I hate them,
if you go back and watch Commercial Kings
is because we got to the
point where we didn't
do them on location, we
said, we'll just do em
when we get back to Los Angeles,
when we're editing.
And we'll know what we need
to say to connect the dots
and we'll just go out into like
a nondescript neighborhood in LA
with one cameraman and a producer
and then you'll connect the dots.
Well what happened was it
was no longer an interview,
it was kinda scripted.
It was like this is the idea
that we need to communicate here.
Yeah.
It was like we've edited it, now you guys
need to put this connected shit together.
You need to say that this
guy, once he went home
and told his mom, and he
was on the verge of tears
to shave his head, you need to articulate
why you let him off the hook and said
you don't have to shave your head,
all you've gotta do is wear the diaper.
Just be the baby for the commercial.
Yeah, that's what we did.
Then you can go back to being the hobo.
And we would have to say that
in the on the fly interview
that we shot months later
and it just didn't have, it wasn't real.
So to wrap this up,
10 years later...
My point is being a producer
on this stuff is like,
it creates like an identity crisis.
No, I think they sleep fine.
It's a certain type of personality.
Let me get to what I'm getting to,
which is...
Get to it.
Well, I've been trying to,
which is 10 years later, reality TV
and people being portrayed
and watching themselves
being portrayed, and
understanding even if they're not
particularly self aware
people who understand
television production.
Almost everyone understands
the manipulative nature
of reality TV now, even the people,
maybe especially the people
who are on it, right?
Yeah, if you watch after
the person wins Survivor
and then it's like the live
show where they're interviewing
everybody who competed that season.
Yeah.
They'll talk openly about how
this is how I was portrayed in the edit.
Well, more specifically,
with 90 Day Fiance, they're so genius
how they figured it out.
If you had to have told me,
hey, so we're gonna do a
show called 90 Day Fiance,
where you know, there's
people getting green cards,
whatever, okay, I got it.
And they were gonna find
all these ways to remix this
and one of the ways is we're
gonna film before the 90 days,
use that footage that we were getting
as they were establishing
their relationship,
okay, that's a show.
And then we're gonna do one
where there's a tell all
where everyone is on a video chat together
and everyone on the video chat
has watched all of the
episodes of the entire season
so now you've got people saying,
commenting on the other couples,
and like butting in and giving advice
about what they should've done, okay,
there's another show, I don't
even know what it's called,
but it's when couples who
have been on 90 Day Fiance
in previous seasons sit in their bedrooms
and watch a current
season of 90 Day Fiance,
and you're just watching
them watch 90 Day Fiance.
And then there's a podcast where a dude
won't shut up about it.
No, but what I'm saying is that
I feel like culturally
we've gotten to a point
where everyone understands
what they're getting themselves into.
You know what I'm saying?
If you've been chatting
for years with somebody
and you're being catfished,
everyone can't understand to the same...
No, no, I'm not saying
that it's not exploitative
in some way, it is, I'm just saying that
10 years have passed and
a whole lot has changed
about the way people
think about the concept
of reality TV and the production.
Everybody knows that the
things that you're watching
on Keeping up with the
Kardashians are produced
scenarios and moments, and
we've gotten to a place
where we don't care anymore, right?
If you're into that kinda
thing, you don't care.
Well, but that's a different,
are you into that?
That's a different type of reality show,
where it's like...
I don't watch that.
Early seasons of Duck
Dynasty is the last time
I've watched anything that
has a point of reference
for these are real people
that then I can tell
that producers have given them a scenario,
hey you're gonna do this.
You knew it and you didn't really care.
You're gonna go hunting,
but here's the problem
that you're gonna encounter.
And you didn't care if
they were good at it,
if they were good at making it happen.
I think, ultimately what I'm saying is,
I'm kinda making a non point in one sense,
because the point that
stands is I still feel
dirty watching it, right?
Regardless of the ethics.
I feel dirtier hearing about 90 Day Fiance
than like the Kardashians
or the Duck Dynasties thing
where it's like the
storylines are manufactured.
Well, yeah, but at the same time,
these people...
Are in on it.
They decided, I do want to do this.
I wanna be in this relationship
and this is a way for me to
actually get a green card
or to be, I mean you have to have
a legitimate, in quotes, relationship.
But when you have an addiction,
like, first of all,
the guy was vindicated.
That's the weird thing about it, kinda.
He was kinda vindicated by it.
But it seems like, and
they didn't know that
when they started filming it.
He needed money to keep paying
for the service, you know?
Somebody at the door?
I think that maybe my
wife may be at the door.
Oh, they're dropping off
a piece of furniture.
I need to go meet them at the door.
Okay.
I got a cramp, I've been
sitting here so long.
See what would be cool is
if a piece of furniture
was delivered in the
middle of the podcast.
What are Rhett and Link gonna do?
You know, Rhett's gonna get up,
is he gonna move the furniture
himself and hurt his back?
Well, let's let him decide,
we know he's got a bad back,
but let's deliver some furniture
and let's see what happens.
Maybe Link will go out there
and say he's gonna move it.
Or he'll probably just assume
that Rhett's gonna ask him
to move it or whatever
because he has a bad back.
It's his fault if he decides
to move the furniture himself
and his back gets thrown out,
there better be cameras there.
There's three in here.
There's not one out there.
We're blowing our opportunity
for a reality TV moment.
It's like here, go, go out there.
That's where the action is.
Oh yeah, it's a table,
it's an outdoor table.
Let me call my wife and ask her.
This is reality right here.
Did the guy, was he
planning on assembling it,
or did you talk him
into it with a Lacroix?
He's assembling it and he has Lacroixs.
Good job.
Can I leave my mask on?
Look, this whole setup looks good.
Everything, oh the mask
really changes the sound,
doesn't it?
Yeah, it's a bit muffled.
So where does that leave us?
We're, we don't want that right there.
Well, okay, so you're back,
there's a guy in there,
he's assembling the table.
I'm out of breath.
Did you move the table?
I just moved.
Did you assemble anything?
This is why, this is the
thing that I didn't anticipate
about COVID is what's happening
with my beard right now.
When I wear a mask.
I mean, mask beard is a real thing.
All right, it's fine.
We should land this reality TV ship.
If we wanna keep it in the
context of the vacation,
to me, it added to my
feeling of worthlessness,
but it was the only thing
that I could really do,
because you can't really go anywhere.
My back was hurt.
You could watch other shows.
You could read a book.
I did that as well.
Apparently there's enough time to do that
and watch seven hours
straight of 90 Day Fiance.
Wow, I mean, when it was over,
did you tally it up and say,
we just watched seven hours?
I think, here's the thing,
me and you married dudes,
who run a business,
and have a lot of stuff that we're doing.
A lot of people do this on the reg.
And so we think that the idea
of sitting down and watching,
but I mean, I talk to some of the folks,
some of the single folks that work for us,
and they're like oh,
yeah, I binged so and so
over the weekend.
Like they watch a whole
season of television
over a weekend.
I've never done that.
And they don't feel worthless.
And I didn't even get to
the bottom of this one.
What do you mean?
There's more of it.
Oh.
But I'm saying some
people are like, oh, yeah
I watched the whole...
Now that you're back home,
are you going back in?
No, no, no, no, no.
Okay, okay, that's a boundary.
That's good, I wanna hear you say it.
I'm not, well, Jesse and
I have a window of time,
sometimes during the week,
between like nine and 10 o'clock
where we'll watch television together.
I don't really watch it
past like, maybe 10:30
is like the latest, right?
I think anything...
10:00 PM can easily turn into 05:00 AM.
Anything goes in that
window, and I would say that,
I would technically allow 90
Day Fiance to go in that window
because there's very
little, like I fall asleep,
I'm not gonna watch it past
10:30 cause I'll fall asleep.
Stakes are low for sleeping.
But I do think that I'd
rather watch something that
is a little bit more plot driven than,
save that as a nice treat, it's just like,
I also had ice cream myself.
I had ice cream twice.
Spoon?
Yeah, I didn't cut myself or anything.
Yeah.
But, I ate ice cream
twice during the week.
I don't eat ice cream outside of our show.
Yeah, I set a boundary.
So it's kinda like I had some junk food,
I had some junk TV, I
feel okay about myself.
I'm trying to be okay with it.
So don't make me feel bad about it.
I felt horrible in the
moment, but damn, that story,
does this woman exist?
She does exist, what?
This is freaking nuts,
I still think it's nuts.
And so where is it right now?
They're engaged?
I think that the last thing
is that they were engaged,
but I think that she's packed out.
Okay.
Or she is MIA for now.
Wow.
So that was our vacation.
Except 30 minutes to
talk about 90 Day Fiance.
I could talk about it forever.
It seems that you could.
I got other things from my
vacation I could talk about.
You know, if you can
watch for seven hours,
two lifelong friends
talking for a long time.
We're gonna make that tagline true,
that's what happens
when you make a tagline.
We got anywhere to be?
You fulfill it.
And there's other meetings.
I think there's one that's
starting maybe even now.
Oh snap.
Well, you've gotta give
your recommendation.
Rec baby, rec baby, one, two, three, four.
So okay, I'm gonna recommend something
that incidentally you're the
one who took it on vacation
and I only knew about it
because Shepard was like,
I think Shepard went to your house, or
I can't remember what it was,
but Shepard comes back
talking about how you were
really excited about something.
He's like Link's really excited about,
he's buying bidets.
Yeah.
And I'm like buying bidets,
and he was like yeah,
a portable bidet.
And I was like, oh, a portable bidet.
I think it came in the
mail when he was there.
That is genius.
Yep, I am.
So I hear about you getting this thing,
and I'm like...
Genius.
You know, I go on vacation,
and I'm sitting there
with a regular American toilet,
I feel like a barbarian,
you know, just wiping my butt with paper,
doing who knows what
to my rectum long term.
You might as well be
wrapping your cheeks around
a tree.
Yeah.
It's still gross.
Just taking a sapling and
just squatting up and down.
A roughed bark sapling, a pine tree.
And I was like, man, I
gotta get me one of these,
and then I go on Amazon,
and it's like 10 bucks
you can get a little squeezy thing.
Oh, I paid more for mine.
Well, mine did the job,
I tested it yesterday.
I got mine in my freaking backpack now
because I don't have anything here.
Mine accordions shut and goes in a bag.
Mine goes in a bag but
it doesn't accordion.
Mine accordions out and it
makes it where you can really
squeeze it.
Does it play music at the same time?
It plays music.
All I know is I recommend this.
Now, first of all, we
recommend bidets in general,
cause we have been talking about that.
And, you know what?
I'm beginning to notice
that the idea of a bidet
is catching on in America.
It is, because of us.
I saw, it's a cultural movement,
we just happen to be part of it.
It's a movement.
We're part of a movement.
There was an Instagram ad
and it was just a little kid
talking about how ridiculous
it was to wipe your butt
with toilet paper, and it was like...
What's the ad for?
A bidet.
Okay, I saw an ad on
Instagram for tooshie.
Yeah, dude.
It's a bidet, here's the
thing, here's what I thought.
You people are resisting this.
It's happening.
Your booty is gonna be
getting sprinkled really soon.
It will happen.
It's happening, cause it's better.
Everybody who does it
loves to gush about it,
no pun intended.
Wow, that's good.
I was on Instagram.
That should be their tagline for it.
I was on Instagram, I
saw an ad for tooshie,
which was an add on to
your toilet that's a bidet.
That should be a sponsor.
And they're not a sponsor,
but they should be a sponsor.
Well, let's make that happen.
And I was prepping for my vacation,
I see this ad, and I say, you know what?
All you gotta do is take
the lid off the toilet,
put it down, put the lid back on
and then hook it up to the
water supply under the toilet,
it's not like, we both have fancy toilets.
Yup.
That do so much more, but I was like,
I'm gonna buy one of these right now
and I'm gonna take it with me on vacation.
That's a good instinct.
So what I did, I bought a bidet.
Or a good in-stink.
And when I tried to hook it up at home,
downstairs so that...
Did you request permission
from your AirBnB host?
No, I didn't.
I'm going to put a bidet
on one of your toilets,
but then I'm gonna take it with me.
I'm gonna leave no trace,
like a good camper.
But I was hooking it up at home
and I was missing a piece
with my type of toilet,
so I had to order that piece,
it didn't come in time,
so I did not take the
tooshie on my vacation.
You took the accordion.
But when I was buying the
tooshie, there was an add on
for an extra 20 bucks,
you can get the accordion
portable, and I was like, this is genius.
Yeah.
I'm genius.
Everybody should have one.
I'm gonna buy this, so I bought that
and I took that with me and
boy, I filled that thing up
and I would squeeze it so hard.
You've really gotta squeeze.
It doesn't give me,
I want the pressure that I get.
Yeah, you can't replicate the pressure.
I jack it up, I jack that
pressure all the way.
Yeah, you can't replicate the pressure.
I can feel it in my throat.
Oh gosh.
But the bottom line is...
That's clean.
Is maybe a good cheap way...
So clean you feel it in your throat.
I don't think that the portable bidet...
Not a sponsor.
The portable bidet is not a
good way to introduce yourself
to the world of bidets,
because you'll be like
this doesn't feel, it's not powerful.
You need a real bidet, but get
like, yeah, get the tooshie.
How much is the one
that's just the add on?
I didn't even look at the price.
It's so good you won't even care.
Oh, the main camera just went to sleep,
so we're gonna finish up this episode
in the singles.
In the singles.
We talk so long we ran the
battery out of this thing.
Man, we had some good vacations, man.
Yeah, we did.
Even if they were bad, they're good now,
because we talked about it so much.
We got two podcasts out of this.
You know how I always want
us, well we can split this up.
No, don't split things,
cause then it's too short.
You know what, this is a bonus for you.
The way that you Americans
just look down your noses
at the idea of bidets and you
ask like stupid questions like
so do you get wet?
Yes, you get wet, you get clean,
you taken a freaking shower before?
It's like a shower for your
butthole, it's not that hard
to understand.
You still wipe.
Yes.
First, then you bidet to get totally clean
and then, if you don't
have a drier on your bidet,
then you dab a little bit more.
Yeah.
But you do an initial wipe
to make sure that you're
not dealing with too much.
Yeah, right now we're first in COVID
and last in bidets.
Let's reverse that.
Come on America.
Yeah.
Do something smart for once.
I can't recommend the tooshie...
Enough.
Appliance yet, because
A, they're not paying me,
and I want you to pay me, tooshie.
Yeah, yeah, tooshie.
I want you to pay him too,
cause I get 50 percent.
I need to test it out,
and I haven't done it, I
just got the piece yesterday
that hooks up to my water supply,
so the jury's still out on the tooshie,
but it looks cool.
You can have different color knobs
and I'll let you know if it, in my rec,
if it works.
This was not a rec, this was rectum.
This is not a recommendation,
this a rectum and effectum.
All right hashtag earbiscuits,
we'll talk at you next week.
Dang, that was a marathon.
It was fun.
To watch more Earbiscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Earbiscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.